oh also you want to talk about the time
i
almost got sexually assaulted by ellen's
oh my god or should we save it for the
regular
oh my god bro talking about this right
now how didn't you talk about that yeah
we're talking about this right now
i almost wonder if we should save it for
the regular uh nah this sample
let's go all right go go go go this is
interesting
so you know the dude this explains
everything i know you so you know the
dude that was the executive producer's
name is
kevin lehman he was out here like
sexually assaulting his staff members
trying to get his dick sucked trying to
suck dicks trying to jerk off dudes
and like all over dude allegedly
allegedly
the lawyer lady up there in the booth is
telling me to say allegedly
well mark reached out to him
yeah mark take it from here so in 2017
what part of him did you grab when you
reached out
in 2017 i reached out to this dude kevin
i was like hey
i'm a fan of ellen i was like trying to
intern in the industry and to try to
like get in
fan of ellen yeah broad liked ellen
that's gayer than sucking that dude's
dick
fannie or daytime talk show surprise
that helen was cool
that was great the show got all right go
to him getting raped go go go
and then i hit him up and i was like hey
man like i would love to like work on
the show can i intern or whatever i was
like making content at the time i was
like yo this would be perfect for the
show let me get in
and then uh he hit me back and he was
like hey man no problem i appreciate you
hitting me up
like things have been crazy but we're
gonna talk like i'll hit you back for
sure summer internships are great
the summer internships are tricky but
we'll get it going and then i hit
hit him up he goes to me he kept on
ghosting me he kept on ghosting me i hit
him up like every day for like
or like every every week for like a
month well that was my whole strategy i
was like
i'll hit people up till they tell me to
[ __ ] off and then i'll just will
and that was a scoreboard yeah
scoreboard bro that's what i'll do to
them
okay go and so he hit me up i hit him up
for weeks like we talked
and then he just goes to me and i just
hit him up two days ago and said
hey man i'm actually going on the
internship i'm all good
and he didn't get back to me no but how
crazy is it that like that dude was
going out there like
sexually assaulting dudes yeah like
trying to suck their dicks
trying to jerk off yeah and he looked at
mark
and he was like nah how do you feel wait
what do you mean you're not
rapeable wait what yo he's smiling they
guys
don't want to smoke you out gators be
[ __ ]
they'd be [ __ ] anything why do you
think they look at you
specifically and they're like and he was
like i
don't want to [ __ ] that no he probably
couldn't handle this
he probably couldn't handle what i said
you think there was you were just too
much for him
in my gap jeans he probably saw what i
had yo do you think that like he was
judging based on like
your like uh preppy cut that you had
back in college like you didn't see the
long hair yeah he doesn't know that i'm
a rugged guy so do you want it like
do you feel at all like a sense of
rejection
at all is there any sense of rejection i
don't need them
i'm happy i need you to be honest
but no is there a little part of you
unrapeable is like a
that's like a that's a shock
that's insulting you are not i can be
assaulted no you cannot yeah if i walk
in a
down the street by myself i put the keys
between my fingers do you yeah
for no reason just in case someone wants
to assault me you know what he wouldn't
be put in between his fingers
dude that i wonder i wonder if kevin
lehman
saw something about you and was like not
my type and
if that if that affects you in any way
well this happened to me before
oh [ __ ] there's nothing
it's not the first gay guy that's turned
you down yeah okay no
not has propositioned me okay this guy's
in proposition
position to him and he said no he did
you was thirsty for
you you were absolutely easy it was like
you know what a girl is like
like yo play hard to get you know gay he
said
rape me [ __ ] weakness basically
he's a will chat will chat that seems
like
yeah he goes with you dog blow off every
chick like yeah yeah
we'll talk later yeah talk about how you
not gonna get this internship you ugly
[ __ ]
yo that's foul that he did that to you
bro
do you feel a way like you know how like
there are girls that probably like
weinstein said no to that's i was just
thinking
where he was like look you're really
talented we're just gonna take this in a
different direction and then yeah
and do you and they're like oh my god
like
like you couldn't even winescheme me
like is that how you feel right now
now you're making me feel that way yo i
am feeling it now i feel like we got to
get to the bottom
of why i'm not the bottom okay
not the bottom yeah by his choice though
yeah we gotta find out like there's
gotta be a little part of you is curious
like what you did to be undesirable
like this that is true now you bring it
up in this specific time i had this one
brazilian girl reach out to me once
like it was after we stopped like
talking and [ __ ] like that yeah and she
uh reached out like months later and she
was like can you just tell me
like what i did wrong
did you no
that's not my job like you know but i
wonder if this is
should i ask you can i want yeah i
wonder if you should shoot an email
message up right now we can fill this
out what do you want me to say
like look you were like sexual
assaulting all these people and
everything like that and obviously
that's 100 wrong
i just want to know why you weren't
interested in doing that to me
was it something i said was it the way i
looked was it my profile picture
yeah yeah okay oh yeah i'll text him has
he seen your message
yeah he's seen all of them he saw the
don't worry about the internship one
oh no he didn't see that yet oh he's
probably going through it now but once
he responds to that then we have no
no you need to send this now so it
sounds like a sincere message hey man i
just want to reach out
and see how you're doing you know i mean
that's going to pop up on his message
[ __ ]
like y'all just want to know what about
me is so unrapable
yeah that's actually kind of hurt my
feelings what do you think is the number
one reason why mark is so unrapable i
don't know because he didn't say
anything
i know why [ __ ] would probably
be giving you all these like facts about
rape during the rape and [ __ ]
he's like actually 99 of victims
you like that actually as a matter of
fact i don't know
stockholm syndrome can present itself in
many cases but
in this specific
we got to get to the bottom of this
kevin lehman bro no cause he can't smell
you over facebook message
[Laughter]
what could it be dude mark
something yo that's a sad it's a sad
story i thought this was going to be fun
i thought somebody tried to rape you
yeah i know
well it turns out nobody tried to rape
you
what a sad story what up people you just
watched a clip from our weekly patreon
episode you can support the flagrancy
you can support this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop
weekly on our patreon at patreon.com
flagrant2 you want to go join you should
because it's a top 10 patreon in the
[ __ ] world that's right for a good
reason go check out why
at patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace
[Applause]